this is a production of Cornell
University
today I will be talking about my PhD
part of my PhD work and
like we have how we have isolated this
key periodical of mutant and how how the
politics regulated in this mutant so
first of all I want to give you a brief
introduction about me I was born and
brought up in near daily like 100
kilometer from daily and I did my
graduation from
so then I I did my graduation from Merit
College Merit in geology party in the
MSC and then I moved to Facebook it's
like
but not this part of India and I did my
like MSC biotechnology with imaginary
major in plant biotechnology and then I
got an opportunity to
work in the University of Hyderabad as a
doctorate so my PSD in my PhD I did
mostly on to identified mutant defective
in Blue Light signaling and we use like
forward and reverse genetic genetics
technique to characterize them and then
I got a
the position in Israel for in World
carry Center and I did like a
collaborative work on
in grape
so with this brief introduction I just
want to go back to a folate so why
folate are important so the most of the
staple food they are very poor in folate
as you can see here like corn rice wheat
potato and cassava they are very very
low in folate so therefore folate
deficiency is the worldwide health
problem with which affect millions of
people so the recommended that allowance
is foreign for the adult and 600 for the
pregnant woman
and the bullet deficiency can cause a
neural defects which include spina
bifida like a spinal cord and uh spine
sign is spinal spines and spinal cord
did not close properly and the enhance
of elephant part of the brain is not
developed properly and many other like
microblastic enemy and high risk of
cardiovascular disease and certain type
of cancer
so that's some of the rich source of
folate like green leafy vegetables
asparagus broccoli and
fermented food products they are very
rich source of folate
so coming to the structure of folate
so Tetra had a folate and there's even
derivative also known as known as folate
they are also like butter soluble form
of vitamin B9 and there are essential
micro nutrient for human health because
human and animals they cannot synthesis
synthesize them they must obtain them
from diet
so this is the structure of folate so
pull it consists of three part
tetrahydro Terrain paraminophenic acid
and the glutamate residue
so up to six glutamate acidity is
attached to the this gamma link amino
acid to make a political terminal Trail
and this polygon terminal is very very
important for folate function because
folate dependent enzyme
transport enzyme polar transporter they
bind to the monoglutamate tail therefore
this folate glutamate tail effect like
cofactor activity as well as the
transport activity and indirectly uh
influence the quality stability
so this terrain thing can exist in both
like dihydrofolate and Tetra hydrofolate
from only the tetrattle tetrah had the
folate form has the uh
cofactor activity
so the N5 and n10 position of
hydrofolate can be attached to
different C1 derivatives they are a
different oxygen different like
oxidation stage they can be attached to
N5 and n10 enzymatically and they're
like inter interconvertible to one
another form by using different enzymes
and this uh for this for folate they are
very sensitive to photo oxidation and
oxidative oxidative damage at this
uh nine and ten position they can break
down very easily to release the terrains
and the power ultimate
so that tied update and there's even
derivative they play very important role
in uh one carbon metabolism where they
where they donate uh one carbon to
different uh reactions as you can see
here uh
tetratopholete interconverted to 510
methylene tetrahed to folate by like it
play very important role in photon
respiration and different folate
derivatives
they provide involved in different uh
metabolic processes they provide their
involvement synthesis of like nucleotide
pyridine and thyroid synthesis uh
vitamin B5 proteins and amino acid
metabolism basically methionine and uh
[Music]
histidine and they're also involved with
amino acid synthesis which in turn
uh synthesize s adenosol methane which
is very important source of like
ethylene and polyamine and the methyl
group from this s adenosine methane
uh is a donor of a different like
protein uh DNA lignin and choline
synthesis
so coming to the folate biosynthesis
folate is present throughout the plant
cell in mitochondria plastic uh
vacuole and cytoplasm but they are only
synthesized in the mitochondria so GTP
cycle hydrolase and the amino Dex
equation synthase they are the rate
limiting enzyme for folate by synthesis
and there they have been used to like
using metabolic engineering to increase
the folate content in different crops so
uh and this is called like
cytoplanic branch is called terrain
branch and uh this amino acid
cosmosynthesis it is called Power Branch
so after synthesis in the terrain branch
in uh this cytoplasm and uh
chloroplasts they are transported to the
mitochondria what tetrahydrofolate
synthesis
synthesized by the action of polypoly
glutamate synthase one residue at a time
uh two form a polygrometer this polymer
tail can be certain or deduced by the
action of gamma glutamate headless which
is present in the vacuum
and in case of adaptation there are
three uh
polypolar glutamate synthase but in case
of tomato there's only two which one is
present in mitochondria and another is
present in uh chloroplast and the there
are three
gamma glutam hydrolase in tomato gh12
and three
so in few of my latest slide I will be
talking about this this terrain path to
intermediate and uh
power path intermediate so like this is
a hydroximately hydrothering and dihydro
uh monetary and dihydro terrain so in
cup in few micellar later I will be
talking about this so just keep them
like
remember
the functional importance of this
polygonomic tail has been done using
this
we have all the three
fpgs Gene exhibit like no cut of all
these three fpgs result in effectively
presented darkness and significant
detection in the methionine level
so there are several strategies have
been used to
develop to improve the folate intake so
one of them is like production and
consumption of foliate food which
require educational effort and change in
the dietary habitat dietary habitat
habit and second is copolic acid
supplementation and fortification this
technique has been you very successful
in developing the developed country but
in case of developing countries it is
not like efficient because of lack of
industrial food system and because of
the different cost
so the third one is a
pull it back by fortification in staple
crop though metabolic engineer it has
been very successful
and like it is a stably substitute and
it has been implemented in tomato and
rice in tomato during this two rate
limited enzyme foreign
strategy and they have increased call it
contained almost like 100 fold but
because of the transgenic nature uh they
are like not in the market and
like because of consumer
raise tents and amid their their health
concern
so the alternate is to explore the
genetic diversity naturally variation in
the it is a cost effective and promising
studies to elevate the micronutrient
deficiency
so in every study we have used this
exploring the natural variation
So based on this background we have
asked few key questions so one of them
is to optimize a high throughput method
for folate analysis in especially in
tomato and the second question to
identify tomato gelas which is this
should be teaching foliate in our we
have a large huge collection of
chromatic system we had a huge
collection of automaticism and the
second objective was to identify
thermody which is Rich and folate and
third objective was to understand the
regulation of folate in this uh in this
General path line
so moving to my
first objective
it's a folate extraction involved
different steps so folate in food is
very sensitive to light temperature heat
and they are present in very very low
amount so folate extraction is very
difficult extraction analysis very
difficult
uh in Elite it is a very challenging
also so try enzyme
is the most commonly used method for
folate extraction so uh Alpha mlase
protease and conjugates they are the
most commonly used enzyme so L5 MLA and
conjugates they break down the
carbohydrate and protein
substance to release the bound uh folate
and conjugates
it uh
uh break the polygutamate tail to
monogrammet tail for folate analysis so
in this is this method is like for we
have adopted this method from D Brewer
which is they have used for Rice which
are very high amount of starch so we
have modified this method for our
analysis so we have a change few like
amount of information pH and other
things to should make it suitable
forever like extracting tomato so
another important thing is that folate
purification it is like very
sensitive so any there are three
different methods are available for
bullet purification advantages solid fat
extraction using Q's approach now there
is definitely chromatography and third
one is ultra filtration using cut off
laminate filter so the drawback of
affinity gravity chromatography is that
it has very low affinity for five methyl
hydropolate which is like SEC third most
abundant foliate form so in our study we
have used uh SP using Q7 but the problem
with Q sephorus is that it has a like 50
50 to 60 percent recovery rate and we
need we need to have very high amount of
salt to elude the folate and again then
we have to dry that uh
and if we are using lcms then they can
get a create a problem in lcms so for
our further State we have used only the
ultra filtration with ultra filtration
is very easy to use just we need to
extend issues and we got uh almost like
95 recovery using 10 kilo Dalton
membrane filter
so using this method we analyze bullet
content in tomato leaf tomato fruit and
different vegetables so one of the
interesting thing we observed that
tomato leaf almost like
more than 40 volt for higher folate in
compared to fruit and the fruit the
volatile measure in other vegetables
were similar to the report in the
literature so
so using this method we found four
different folate form
five methyl tetraid of folate was the
most abundant folate form and
tetrahydroflate was the like least
dominant foliate form
so in summary
we're using this method we found a
better recovery like which is very
sensitive and like a extraction was fast
compared to other method and since we
have used lcms so it was like very
accurate up to five decimal and in like
single day we can extract almost like 40
sample a day and this method is equally
applicable to other vegetables as
so moving to our second objective we
have a large collection of tomato from
different resources like DJ is a private
company and Indian Institute of
vegetable research a National Bureau
plant genome research and tgrc UC Davis
so we have around 391 taxation so we
have grown them like we have grown them
you can see in the picture I am not
there I'll just take the picture and we
have transferred them to field and in
this you can see the
so one of the biggest problem we have
faced like lost because of wild boar
peacock and his parents we have lost
almost 60 percent of our
so
using this uh method this is just a
representative picture using this method
we have analyzed folate content in 125
chromatic season so we have seen a wide
various in polite content so from this
we have selected two
uh foreign
so
these avian take them like well known
cultivar in Southern India and they are
grown in similar anglicrimatic
conditions
so
we have re-examined the pullet content
in the Next Generation to check whether
like the folate is
again like high so we have collected
fruit from three different stage Metro
Green breaker and red right so in case
of tomato these
uh stages are very very important
especially the breaker stage when fruits
start to ripe they start to synthesize
accumulating carotenoids and there's the
bust of ethylene and respiration rate
and they start to accumulate like Flavor
also
so we exam the folate content in PKM
again although the folate content was
lower compared to the previous previous
season but it still it is more than
two-fold higher so
uh
in spite of having this environmental
seasonal difference we have
selected AV and PKM
to understand the bullet variation so in
the fourth subsequent experiment we have
grown these AV and PKM in Greenhouse to
avoid any environmental differences
so the online root ripening of Av and
PKM were
almost similar they reach the maximum
size at around 30 days and the Metro
gain stage is around 32 days so mature
gain to breaker stage a p cam reach
around 7 days and AV reach around four
days so there was a difference of three
days in AVN PTM as you can see here
and fruit happening is also accompanies
with increasing sugar content so we have
measure of the bricks content so if the
light drive stage became a significantly
High bricks compared to AV
so another a major difference we have
seen is the increase sorry decrease in
ethylene content in PKM at breaker and
red wrap is this so like ABA like
ethylene ABS was also almost half in PKM
at the 3D all the three differences
stages
and we have seen salicylic acid and
jasminic acid
lower in like stage specific manner so
we did the like protemic study
and we found some protein related to
ethylene biosynthesis which were like
ac01 ac06 which are like expressed
during food type food is specific
methylene synthesis because they were
very low in a pkm1
and so we thought that
reduce
level of this hormones may be related to
ethylene because in one of the paper
recently the under producer of ethylene
us have low level of ABA salicylic acid
and just magnetic acid
so as I you can see the Greenhouse grown
plant have lower folate compared to the
field ground but still the folate
contains was very high a significantly
high in PKM all the on all three
different stages and the bullet content
was decreasing strategic decline from
match again to Red rapid stage the
decline was faster in case of PKM in
case of sorry in case of AV
so to check whether the folate content
is high only in the root or it is like
affecting the leaf also so we have
measured the pole containing Leaf also
so Leaf also so the uh high level of
significantly high quality content and
we have to seen the four different
project form
so the next question was whether High
folate in PKM is because of a precursor
which is Baba and terrines
so like folate power content was also
high in PKM in all the three different
stages
um we could not detect the terrain
derivatives because we presume that they
are presenting very very low amount but
we could able to see a hydroxy
methyltine which is like oxidized form
of hydroxy methyl dihydratory and low
level of this is considered okay
so low level of this is considered that
Salvage path is more efficient in
recycling the hydroximity
as you can see here the folate synthesis
as well as the folate
breakdown and Salvage pathways usually
go parallel so tired for it it is
degraded to terrine and power glucose so
terrine in different enzymes like enzyme
enzymatic and known enzymatic state is
converted to dihydrotonin 6 ldi aldehyde
this ptar enzyme is very efficient it
has very very high activity it can
convert this to six hydroxy
dimethyltyrene and it can use it can be
used in the Salvage pathway but
sometimes they are these enzymes fail to
intercept uh I had to tell in 6 ldi so
they again oxidize two terrines six ldes
which are
uh like this PTR has very like broad
spectrum specifically so if
they fail to intercept this it is
converted to this by like a light or
what no enzymatic means and again 26
ldhyde is converted to hydroxy six
hydroximately 10 which cannot be used
for like Salvage Pathways so low level
of this means that Salvage pathway is
much more efficient and it can be used
for a foliage synthesis
so the next question about whether High
folate in PKM is because of the
expression of folate uh biosynthesis
Gene so but like we have not seen a find
much significant difference in our
analysis uh all the gene have more or
less similar expression in case of ADN a
b and tkm so we we thought that maybe
some like regulation is somewhere else
other than this polar device synthesis
Gene transcripts
so next we have measure the
transcript level of gamma glutam
hydrolage Gene so we found that ggh1
ggs2 and ggs3 they are their label was
significantly low in
PKM at the especially at the red Drive
is stage
uh after that we have checked the GH
enzyme activity at DJs enzyme activity
so we found that enzyme activities was
very high it uh match again it stays and
they stated decline from as that
happening progressed so but we don't
find any significant difference in avian
PKM at the metric unit instead but at
the breaker stage the ggs activity was
significantly high in PKM and they were
significantly low in at a stage
and the folate polygrittamate label uh
is this it is hypothesized that
political
termite is the stable form and they are
very they are less sensitive to
degradation or catabolism so we measure
the folate monoglutamate and
polyglutamate label in AV and PKM is at
the right time stage and we found that
PKM has significantly high
polyglutamate level at RR type stage
all right so recently like not recently
one paper came where they have over
expressed this ggh enzyme and they found
that over expression of ggh in vacuole
reduce folate polygonal tail length and
the following time was received almost
40 percent
so next we have measure whether hypolate
in PKM may have any friends of
carotenoid biosynthesis pathway
so we measure the cabinet content in AV
and PKM at the right these these py
diagrams so the like proportional ratio
so if at Red Devil stage AB like pkm1
has almost like 1.5 volt hair pull it uh
compared to AV and they have like
lycopene and beta coordinate almost 1.5
volt higher
so next we examine whether High folate
level High character level in in P cam
is because of the transcript level of
the genes so at Metro Green and Breakers
most of the landscape did not differ
significantly their labels are almost
similar in AV and PKM but it
red ripe stage few of the genes which
synthesize lycopene were significantly
low in case of PKM
so then we did the
glutamic study and we found some of the
protein which help in carotenoid
sequestration were high in case of PKM
like Pap three hair preventing protein
and chrc they are known to play a role
in character sequestration so carotenoid
in
ah plastic they are stored in
lipoprotein-like structure like called
the
globules so these proteins are component
of those globules and
as you can see here the in tomato they
have overexpressed fibrin fibrillion
protein
so you over expression of this result in
in please
keratin content and the carotenoid
volatiles similarly in tomato High
pigment which accumulate high level of
carotenoid they also have high level of
chrc protein
so as like bullet play in potential in
in civil metabolism so we examine
whether is there any influence on
overall overall proteome so we use the
gcms to
identify different metabolite so
we using gcms we identify 69 metabolite
which include amino acids sugars organic
acid and fatty acids sugar derivatives
so as you can see in this figure most of
the metal metabolite was significantly
significant and PCA analysis so the
clustering of different metabolite at
different stages of ripening and PKM so
therefore separate cluster at each
ripening stage
then we have mapped these metabolite on
a metabolic pathway
so one of the interesting things we
observed that most of the amino acid
Works significantly higher in case in
PKM as you can see the the flat scale
and
sugars and others they are like very
initiative stage specific stage specific
person
so like I have shown the previously that
in PK and there's the Dick's content was
very very high so
in our product study we found this
circular synthase
so high level of bricks and sugar and so
close in pkm1 may be related to high
level of like high level of support
centers so we found two proteins related
to glycolysis
Head release
so they are the precursor for synthesis
or synthesis of
like past particular kinase it is
precursor for synthesis of serine
glycine and cysteine so we thought that
high level of this may be responsible
for responsible for the high amount of
these amino acid and the phospho
pyruvate kinase may be responsible for
the leucine valine and alanine amino
acid
and like we also found high level of
economies so we
believe that high level of faculties may
be pushing precursor for synthesis or
glutamate and we found two more protein
like glutamate synthase and glutamine
cities which may be responsible for high
level of glutamine and Parabola Tomatoes
glutamate
and we also found a very low level of uh
gamma transom image
so it has been reported that over
silencing of gamma transform Ms increase
Gaba level in tomato fruit
so in every case the the low level of
gamma transom transformation age may be
responsible for a high level of Kaaba
so in summary
a sample and high throwback method was
developed which is easy and high
throughput and which is equally
applicable to other crop also
stage
and lower GG's activity and high
polyglutamine level in ARA fruit likely
contribute to high folate in pkm1
keratin sequestration protein seems to
be
regulator of increased character level
in pkm1
and pkm1 fruit have elevated level of
three nutraceutical folate carotid and
Kaba so recently Japan has launched this
genome added tomato which are very rich
in Gaba so we also got a similar kind of
result
so now here in the Tech Lab I am working
on like phenolis content so in the
uh I have optimized two method for
analyzing phenonics monomer and the
polymer which is 10 in so I just want to
give a brief introduction about
phenolics so phononics our second class
of secondary metabolites which are
involved in organelle organelle optic
criteria such as color which is provided
by 11 3 ohms like category categame and
hydroxycine chlorogenic acid and
bitterness and estrogens is provided by
11 300 catechino and tenants and they
also provide the colloidal stability to
the side
so they are the precursor of cider
Aromas and flavor like hydroxycinoma
ceramic acid which provide correct
testing flavor to Kingston high price
Kingston Apple
and they are broadly divided into five
different categories eleven period which
include catechin epicate again
hydroxycinomate which include
chlorogenic acid and hydrocalcone
fluoride Gene 11 liquorsetian
anthocyanins so these are the like
structure of few of the
um
phenolics yeah
so one one of our like
previously remember he did uh he did a
screening of a large accession of uh
malice germ Plus
okay so the sad industry is one of the
fastest growing Market in U.S and they
are not enough cider varieties which can
be used potentially used for hard
Saturday making the essential uh the
requirement for high salaries like this
would have a high amount of tannin so he
did with this objective he screened this
158 malice accession from USDA pgru and
uh so he found that total phonics
content using Paul inch equal to the
total Finance content varies from 0.39
mg per liter to 4.86 uh induced sampling
and these to another spy and Elizabeth
they are the commercial uh varieties
which are used for cider making but like
interesting interesting things he
observed that two of the varieties have
also have the high level of total
Phoenix phenolics which can be used for
potentially presided industry
so he did the like total finally
phenolics analysis and I optimized
method for like to analyze the knowledge
monomer using hplc so using hplc we
identify around 19 phenolics
monomers in all these these 40 14
varieties cultivar and
if you see the individual chronologics
many of them has had higher phenolics
monomer compared like category like all
the 11th theorems compared to the
commercial inside where it is Alice
bitter and
leatherness by
and we did the PCA bipload analysis
and we found this
prosenidine B1 and chlorogenic acid are
the
factor which determine the pc1 and PC2
[Music]
variation
so the other objective was to optimize
the method metaphor hplc so just take
brief 100 introduction about prosenadine
and over condensed any so they provide
much fuel to the cider and if they are
their meaning degree of polymers is six
to eight or more they provide estimency
and if they are lower than that they
provide betterness so they are the
oligomer and polymer of category
replicate epic epicate again is present
in both like as you can see uh telomere
unit as well as the extension unit and
the catechin is present only on
extension unit so we use the
fluoroglycerol method which hydrolyze a
10 in polymer to monomer and it release
the terminal unit as a free form and it
form addict with the the extension unit
so using this method we have measure the
Tenon content in order for affection so
in life less tissue so we have found
that uh training content in
quarter Perfection is 15 mg per gram
Drive weight and the average molecular
weight is
300 3000 Dalton and mean degree of
polymerization is around 11
um okay
I'm almost done
but this is
I would like to thank my professor RP
Sandman Dr Vice Lakshmi and all the lab
member and the funding body Department
of biotechnology which provide fund for
this department for this project
and Council of scientific and Industry
research for providing Fellowship to me
during my doctorate
and thank you
any questions
double has there been a effort in India
to
um
to focus on growing more tomato
varieties with higher folate with that
now that you've screened all those
accessions and you know which ones have
higher folate naturally has there been
any sort of effort to commercialize
those more actually this like PKM it is
already a commercial variety and there
is grown in South India but this paper
came recently so maybe they will read
this paper and hopefully they will
like implement this
as I understand uh you know a lot of
places
genetically engineered crops or you have
a lot of um actually cultural and
political consumer
um issues baggage yes baggage would be a
good word and so I know in India that's
been true with like the eggplant and so
I'm wondering about just kind of uh
might be more interest in some of the
natural naturally High
cultivars versus the um the genetically
engineered ones little people don't know
about this like PKM but now maybe
they will start growing this more and
more
thank you so much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu